you know ever since I was a kid my dream
has always been to make movies better
and you're not making them better we're
making fun of them it's not fun anymore
I'm just killing them you and I have a
convent sure to go on I don't remember a
green is this there's hot women and
don't you see Danny's gone you were out
there trying to separate us they're
trying to separate us trying to separate
us would you rather be sober when the
IKEA punch comes and makes a rooty tooty
fresh and fruity breakfast platter at
your ass would you rather be sober when
the IKEA bunch comes and makes a booty
okay y'all said to hang out not exactly
I mean not exactly
sorry I don't know what's more racist
than the fact that he's in blackface or
the fact that he's being sold for $22
either way somebody should be offended